- [Interviewer] Yup.
(motor running)
- [Interviewer] All right, Isela?
Isela, where are you from originally?
- [Isela] Guadalajara, Jalisco.
Mexico?
- Mexico.
- [Interviewer] And how long have you been
in the United States?
30 years.
- 30 years?
Yeah.
- It's a long time.
- Yeah, long time.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about your childhood.
You grew up with your
parents, both parents?
- Yeah, with my parents.
- [Interviewer] And you
started, I mean, so you
were a man at one point?
- Oh yeah.
- [Interviewer] What age
did you become a woman?
- When I get my first
dressed like a woman was on
1987.
- Okay.
So this has been a long time for you?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And how
did your family take that?
- The first time no good.
- [Interviewer] (laughs) I'll bet.
- But little by little they
look at me like a woman
and now it's okay, everything.
It's okay?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
So you go home and visit
and everything is fine?
- All the time I'm dressing like a woman.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I wouldn't know.
You look like a beautiful woman to me.
- Yeah, I'm a woman right now.
Yeah, all woman?
- All woman.
Downstairs too?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
So where did you have that procedure done?
The doctor does that for you?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And where
is the doctor, in Mexico or-
In Mexico.
- In Mexico?
Yeah.
- It's a painful surgery (laughs)?
A lot of pain.
- A lot of pain?
Yeah.
- I bet, I bet.
But you're happier now?
I'm happy
- Yeah.
Yeah.
Did you know as a child
that this was what you were,
you were meant for this, you
were supposed to be a woman?
Do you think, as a child?
- Yeah, yeah, this was my child.
- [Interviewer] Was it
difficult for you as a child?
- No.
With the other kids?
It was fine, that's good.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So here we
are at four in the morning
and you're on the street,
picking up men, right?
Yeah.
- How is that?
Try and get money.
- Trying to make money.
How much money do you make in a week
in a night, say it's Friday night?
- I just got out only two hours.
- [Interviewer] You only
go out for two hours?
- But not all the time, only two times
or three times a month.
- Oh Really?
You have another job?
- No.
Just this?
- Just this.
- So you pick up men at
the end of their night
out drinking and partying
and getting high?
- I don't drink.
- [Interviewer] No but
the men that pick you up?
- Oh yeah.
- [Interviewer] They're drunk,
they've been drunk all night.
- They're drunk and it's not easy for us.
- Yeah, no, I'm sure
they're violent sometimes?
- Sometimes, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Tell me a story,
I'm sure you've had crazy
things happen with men, right?
- [Isela] Yes, one time one man take me
a little far away this area.
- Yeah.
- [Isela] And he take me,
he take me out of my clothes and after
that they don't wanna
give, he don't wanna give
me my clothes 'cause two guys in the car.
One in the front and one in the trunk.
- [Interviewer] Oh no.
- [Isela] When we stay in
the place to do something,
the other guy get up from the trunk.
- [Interviewer] Now there's two guys?
- [Isela] Yeah, two guys
and take me the clothes off.
And they don't wanna give me my clothes.
And I walk all the way
down with no clothes on me.
How far?
- Like one mile.
- [Interviewer] Oh my God,
(laughs) in the middle
of the night you're walking
naked down the street.
- Yeah, but that person 20 years ago.
- [Interviewer] He was dangerous.
- [Isela] Pretty dangerous,
it's not easy for us.
There's--
This is a tough life.
- The job.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, it's a tough job.
Have you been in prison, do the cops
arrest you sometimes?
- Sometimes, yeah.
- [Interviewer] How many
times have you been arrested?
Three
- Three.
- [Interviewer] And it's
just for a day or so?
Yes, for a few days.
- Few days?
- The last time was in a week.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
- My last arrest was 2001,
long time ago.
- [Interviewer] So it's been a while.
The cops leave you alone now?
Yeah.
- That's good.
So your breasts are hormones
or implants or both?
It's breast implants.
- Implants.
Yeah.
- They're big and beautiful.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] So when
you visit your family,
you're all, you're 100%
woman, all the time?
- All the time I'm looking
and dressing like a woman.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, no,
you're very convincing.
- Anywhere, at the stores and my house,
with my family, with my sisters.
- [Interviewer] And you
take hormones as well?
No more.
- No more?
- No more hormones.
- [Interviewer] Excellent,
well thank you so much
for talking to me.
Okay.
- All right.
You're welcome.
- All right, thank you.